Speaker 1: Let's talk to why don't we go to
Andrew from Miami.
Andrew, you're on the air.
Hi, David.
I can.
Speaker 6: Hey, so I was curious what your
opinion was of Nancy Pelosi recently investing
10 million dollars in Microsoft.
Speaker 1: I didn't know that she did what
she bought 10 million dollars worth of of
Microsoft stock.
Speaker 6: Correct, around a month ago, she
invested upwards of 10 million dollars in
Microsoft stock, and then shortly after that,
Microsoft received a government contract for
a pretty large sum of money and then the stock
went up.
Speaker 1: You know, there is a lot of stuff
about Nancy Pelosi that is that is untrue.
And I want to be careful because there's a
rumor that Nancy Pelosi is worth one hundred
and ninety six million.
But it seems she's really only worth five
million dollars.
So when you're telling me she invested 10
million, I just I haven't heard that.
And I'm just unsure about that.
I think her husband is quite wealthy.
I don't know, because of all of the incorrect
stuff.
I just don't know.
Speaker 6: Yeah, her husband just owns a major
investment firm, so he has ties to Wall Street
and then she directly acts on legislation
that would affect the stocks that she invest
in.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, listen, I've come
out before and I've said that it is too easy
to violate the STOCK Act for members of the
House and Senate.
There are real questions about that being
not nearly regulated enough.
And I apply that to Republicans as much as
Democrats specifically, Nancy, investing 10
million went as far as I know, her net worth
is five.
I just I just don't know about that.
Speaker 6: Gotcha.
I mean, just in light of her recent comments
as well, after the show trial, it just seems
like she's a liability.
Speaker 1: Democrats and her comments about
the showband thing were for people who don't
know, she said something like, I want to thank
George Floyd for sacrificing himself in the
name of justice or whatever.
It's like, whoa, hold on a second.
He didn't he didn't sacrifice himself.
And that's really strange language.
And it seems an insanely and that was just
a major faux pas.
Speaker 6: I agree.
So it seems like she's a liability to Dems
and almost seems like she wants Republicans
to win in the midterms.
Speaker 1: I don't think she wants Republicans
to win.
I just think she's making missteps.
Why would she want Republicans to win?
Speaker 6: It would lengthen her ability to
continue fighting for corporations as opposed
to actually people's interests now.
Speaker 1: Now, that doesn't ring, right?
I don't think so.
I think Nancy Pelosi certainly to some degree
is focused on herself.
But I have no reason to think she wants Republicans
to win.
Speaker 3: Interesting.
Thanks so much, David.
Speaker 1: All right, pleasure.
Great to hear from you.
OK, let's see who else we can hear from because
we really have been having some beautiful
phone calls today.
Excellent, excellent calls.
Let's talk to Lucas from Hendersonville.
Where is Hendersonville, by the way?
Speaker 3: Hey, it's north of Nashville.
Speaker 1: Oh, OK.
Hendersonville, Tennessee.
Very beautiful.
Speaker 3: OK.
Yes, sir.
Thank you.
My question to you is that there is about
10 million illegal immigrants in the U.S.
What steps should Biden take to help accommodate
those people and to the American society that
we have to do?
Speaker 1: Well, I think you have to kind
of go in in stages.
And the first thing is DACA has to be dealt
with.
There has to be a permanent solution on DACA.
It's hard for me to to lay out a full policy
sequence because so much of it depends on
if, how and when DACA is dealt with.
I do think that a clear path to citizenship
should be put in place.
I mean, I don't have any any unique particular
view on this.
It's it's what you know, I like what people
like Roxana have talked about on immigration
and, you know, Congressman Ruben Gallego and
others just just kind of a just reasonable
system where we're treating people with respect
and we're understanding that the vast majority
of undocumented immigrants are here working,
paying into systems and raising families,
et cetera.
Yeah, I don't have anything groundbreaking
on that.
Speaker 3: Thank you.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Appreciate the phone call.
OK, that is going to close today's call session.
I, of course, am deeply sorry that I was not
able to get to more people, but we we do operate
with a time limit and we are going to be back
with many more phone calls very, very soon.
We'll take a quick break and be back with
much more after this.